[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport
Rückenwind für schnelleren Ausbau die
Regierung will Windräder weitgehend ohne
Prüfung der Umweltverträglichkeit
genehmigen
Ultimatum an Maßen die CDU-Spitze
fordert den Rechtsaußen zum
Parteiaustritt auf wegen antisemitischer
und völkischer Äußerungen
und wieder wärmeres Wasser einige
Schwimmbäder können sich einen höheren
Gasverbrauch leisten und wollen
Badegäste zurückgewinnen
[Musik]
im Moment kommt etwa die Hälfte des
deutschen Stromverbrauchs aus
erneuerbaren Energien die
Bundesregierung will den Anteil schnell
deutlich steigern dafür hat das Kabinett
jetzt einen wie Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck es nennt
windausbaubeschleuniger auf den Weg
gebracht damit soll die Genehmigung von
Windrädern Solaranlagen und Wärmepumpen
viel schneller werden so hat Karl die
berichtet
die Erneuerbaren im Norden deutlich
sichtbar bis 2030 sollen sie 80 Prozent
des Strombedarfs in Deutschland decken
so will es die Politik doch der Ausbau
erstockt jetzt drücken die Regierung und
der zuständige Minister aus Tempo häufig
wurde dafür darüber geklagt dass das
alles so schwergängig ist und dass man
nicht genau weiß wie man das mit
Artenschutz und Denkmalschutz sind
Übereinstimmung bringen soll das ist
jetzt alles geklärt und ich erwarte und
hoffe dass die Bundesländer jetzt mit
diesen Mitteln auch dass ihre tun die
den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
Energienetzwerk zu setzen
Genehmigungen Verfahren schneller
einfacher sollen sie werden das
Bundeskabinett billigte heute die neuen
Regelungen für einen beschleunigten
Ausbau der Wind Energie Umwelt und
Artenschutzprüfung fallen in vielen
Fällen weg
wer beschleunigt muss aufpassen dass er
nicht in der Leitplanke landet dieses
Gesetz hat das Potenzial dafür eine
erhebliche Bresche in das
Naturschutzrecht zu schlagen die Branche
der Erneuerbaren sieht das naturgemäß
anders mehr grüner Strom aus heimischer
Erzeugung sei jetzt wo Deutschland sich
unabhängig von russischen Gas machen
will wichtiger denn je es zeigt so ein
bisschen den Geist der Bundesregierung
die jetzt vorgibt dass das Ziel möglich
gemacht werden muss auch Solaranlagen
und Wärmepumpen sollen künftig viel
schneller genehmigt werden nämlich
binnen 3 Monaten habe ich Entwurf geht
jetzt zunächst an den Bundestag
vor 30 Jahren war der
Solidaritätszuschlag eingeführt worden
um die Kosten der deutschen Einheit zu
finanzieren seit zwei Jahren zahlen ihn
nur noch Besserverdiener und Unternehmen
und FDP wollten den Zuschlag längst
abschaffen und auch der Bund der
Steuerzahler sieht die Abgabe kritisch
doch eine Klage gegen den Soli
scheiterte heute Birgit franke hat mehr
er zahlt die noch den Soli Malermeister
und Geschäftsführer Ivo Fuhrmann aus
Hohenbrunn dass der Bundesfinanzhof die
Abgabe heute bestätigt hat ist für ihn
eine Enttäuschung warum soll ich jetzt
dann als etwas besser verdienter immer
noch weiter bezahlen die anderen Zahlen
nicht mehr ich finde es einfach unfair
der Bundesfinanzhof hingegen sieht den
so die heute weiterhin als rechtens an
es besteht nach wie vor ein
wiedervereinigungsbedingter Finanzbedarf
des Bundes der in den Jahren 2020 und
2021 die Erhebung des
Solidaritätszuschlags rechtfertigt
erhöhte Kosten bestimmten weiterhin etwa
bei der Rentenversicherung und im
Arbeitsmarkt außerdem habe der
Gesetzgeber den Soli ab 2021 beschränkt
auf Unternehmen und besser verdienende
aktuell Zahlen ledige den so die erst ab
einem zu versteuernden Jahreseinkommen
von
62.600 Euro bei zusammen veranlagten
Paaren sind es
125.200 € durch diese Beschränkung habe
der Arbeitgeber deutlich gemacht dass er
den Soli nicht unbegrenzt erheben will
so die Richter der Bundesfinanzminister
will den Soli schon länger abschaffen
auch weil Unternehmen ihn nach wie vor
uneingeschränkt zahlen müssen politisch
und ökonomisch müsste der
Solidaritätszuschlag entfallen das wäre
die schnellste Form einer Stärkung
unserer wirtschaftlichen
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit für die Betriebe
zumindest für die Zukunft kann ibufo man
hoffen dass auch eher den Soli
irgendwann nicht mehr zahlen muss
schon länger hadert die CDU mit ihrem
Mitglied Hans-Georg Maaßen jetzt hat die
Parteispitze dem früheren
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten ein
Ultimatum gestellt entweder er verlässt
bis Sonntag freiwillig die Partei oder
es wird ein Ausschlussverfahren
eingeleitet Maßen Gebrauche die Sprache
aus dem Milieu der Antisemiten und
verschwörungsideologen so die Begründung
des CDU-Präsidiums
sprachmaßen von Zitat rot grüner
Rassenlehre er selbst nannte das
Vorgehen seiner Partei heute in der
Zeitung die Welt unklug die
Voraussetzungen für einen Ausschluss
legen nicht vor von 2012 bis 2018 war
Maßen Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes
musste dann aber den Posten räumen unter
anderem nachdem er rechtsextreme
Ausschreitungen in Chemnitz in Zweifel
gezogen hatte
fragen wir Theo Koll in Berlin wie
schwer wird es für die CDU Maßen
loszuwerden
ich glaube das dürfte extrem schwierig
werden die SPD hat zehn Jahre gebraucht
um Tilo Sarrazin loszuwerden Maßen wird
nicht von sich ausgehen denn die CDU
Mitgliedschaft verschafft ihm ja die
Aufmerksamkeit die als Abweichler sucht
und er hat sich gerade erst im
Vorsitzenden der sogenannten werteunion
wählen lassen also einer
Nationalkonservativen Gruppierungen von
nach eigenen Angaben 4000 Menschen die
zum größten Teil unionsmitglieder sein
sollen und für sich reklamieren den seit
Merkel vernachlässigten Flügel der CDU
zu vertreten dass dieser Verein am
Wochenende in der ausgerechnet Maßen zum
Vorsitzenden gewählt hat war natürlich
eine Art Kampfansage an die eigene
Partei die dann heute genauso Klage
geantwortet hat gleichzeitige
Mitgliedschaften in CDU und werteunion
sein ab sofort unvereinbar dahinter
scheint dann auch die Frage der
Brandmauer nach ganz rechts durchmaßens
Vorgänger in der werteunion hatte sich
um das Amt des Bundespräsidenten
beworben und zwar als Kandidat die AFD
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung aus
Berlin Theo Koll
der Mangel an Rohstoffen machte
Industrie Sorgen um die Abhängigkeit von
China zu mildern will Bundeskanzler
Scholz neue Lieferanten gewinnen zum
Beispiel Chile auf seiner
Südamerika-Reise hat Scholz mit der
chilenischen Regierung eine
rohstoffpartnerschaft vereinbart dort
gibt es viel Lithium und das ist wichtig
für Elektroautos deutsche Firmen sollen
Chile beim nachhaltigen Bergbau
unterstützen
der Bundeskanzler und auch der neue
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius haben
ihre ablehnende Haltung zu Kampfjets für
die Ukraine bekräftigt die USA und
einige andere Staaten halten eine
Lieferung grundsätzlich für möglich bei
russischen Angriffen sind im Süden und
Osten der Ukraine wieder Zivilisten ums
Leben gekommen Antoine kuscheln
ein zerstörtes Haus in harkev im Osten
der Ukraine getroffen von einer
russischen Rakete mindestens ein
Bewohner wird getötet mehrere verletzt
die Rakete die die russische Armee hier
mitten in ein Wohnhaus gefeiert hat hat
die Menschen in der Nacht überrascht es
gab keine Chance zu entkommen rund 200
km südlich von Harke die Front in
bachmut heftig umkämpft seit Monaten
die Ukraine haben diesen russischen
Panzer erbeutet und setzen ihn jetzt an
der Front ein aber es fehlen Panzer
berichtet der Kommandant dieser Einheit
und wartet auf den deutschen Leopard
sie sind wir werden den Umgang mit
diesem Kampfpanzer nicht in einer Woche
lernen ich denke vier Wochen sind
realistisch aber der Krieg hat gezeigt
dass wir recht schnell mit neuer
Technologie umgehen können
in der Luft sind die Russen überlegen
sagen militär-experten was auch diese
Propaganda Bilder zeigen sollen heute
veröffentlicht vom
Verteidigungsministerium russische
Kampfjets im Einsatz im ukrainischen
Luftraum es gibt Berichte dass die
Russen im Osten weiter vorrücken was die
Ukraine dementieren aber
die Situation ist sehr ernst Städte wie
bachmut und wuchle da sowie andere Orte
in der Region dorniert werden ständig
bombardiert
ebenso im Visier der Russen im Süden der
Ukraine
Raketenangriffe unter anderem auf ein
Krankenhaus auch hier Tote und Verletzte
in Pakistan gab es eine verheerende
Explosion in pescha war im Nordwesten
des Landes bei dem Selbstmordanschlag in
einer Moschee starben mindestens 59
Menschen mehr als 100 Gläubige wurden
verletzt noch hat sich niemand zu dem
Attentat bekannt in den vergangenen
Wochen haben die pakistanischen Taliban
mehrere Anschläge für sich reklamiert
zuvor hatten sie die Waffenruhe mit der
Regierung aufgekündigt Norman Odenthal
berichtet
wenn es noch Hoffnung auf Überlebende
geben sollte dann muss es jetzt sehr
schnell gehen unter den Trümmern hält es
sicher keiner lange aus der Attentäter
hat das Mittagsgebet gewählt zu dieser
Zeit sind immer besonders viele
Polizisten in der Moschee die vor allem
waren wohl das Ziel
wir waren gerade auf dem Weg zum Gebet
waren noch draußen auf den Stufen vor
der Moschee da ist es drinnen passiert
wir konnten einigen Verletzten helfen
aber die Toten sind alle drinnen unter
den Trümmern
ständig müssen Sie die Opferzahlen
korrigieren ständig werden es mehr von
einem Selbstmordanschlag geht die
Polizei aus die Wucht der Detonation
brachte Teile der Decke zum Einsturz
viele Gläubige in der Moschee hatten
überhaupt keine Chance der Tod traf sie
im Gebet
es war so ein Chaos ich habe sieben
Menschen herausgezogen und in den
Krankenwagen geschafft zwei sind dort
gestorben fünf konnten wir ins
Krankenhaus bringen
dort herrscht medizinischer Notstand so
viele kämpfen noch ums Überleben
Blutspenden werden dringend gebraucht
wieder einmal wurde jede Hoffnung auf
Frieden auf ein Ende des Terrors im Park
ist dann brutal zerbombt in die Moschee
von Pescher war waren hunderte gekommen
um zu beten einer um zu töten
es war montag der 30 Januar heute vor
genau 90 Jahren kamen die
Nationalsozialisten in Deutschland an
die Macht an diesem Tag marschieren die
Nazis durch das Brandenburger Tor und
feiern sich selbst als Sieger der
letzten freien Reichstagswahlen kurz
darauf einen Reichspräsident Hindenburg
Hitler zum Reichskanzler es beginnt das
dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen
Geschichte
als Zeichen gegen Extremismus und gegen
die Spaltung der Gesellschaft
versammeln sich in Leipzig die Bilder
müssten jetzt kommen
zur Stunde tausende Menschen
Thomas Bersch berichtet aus Leipzig mit
den Friedensgebeten in der Nikolaikirche
nahmen 1989 die friedliche Revolution
ihren Anfang auch der heutige Montag
beginnt hier mit dabei Leipziger die
heute Abend die Stadt zum Leuchten
bringen wollen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die ein Anliegen teilen
ich habe das Gefühl dass in dieser Zeit
unsere Gesellschaft ziemlich
auseinanderdriftet und das was viele
Jahre einfach selbstverständlich war
dass wir in der Demokratie leben und in
Freiheit leben alles andere als
selbstverständlich ist und deshalb bin
ich hier ich bin gegen die Spaltung in
dieser Gesellschaft wir mussten viel
mehr Brücken bauen wir müssen
miteinander reden es ist nicht zufällig
ein Montag an dem Gewerkschaften Kirchen
oder Parteien ein Zeichen setzen wollen
gerade weil
Montagsdemonstrationen die DDR ins
Wanken brachten stehen sie symbolisch
für die Kraft die Menschen auf die
Straße bringen und damit auch Erfolg
haben können
Montagsdemos gab es nach dem Mauerfall
in Leipzig für Olympia gegen Hartz 4
gegen den Irakkrieg den Flüchtlings
Zuzug 2015 oder gegen corona-maßnahmen
doch die Vereinsamung des Montags auch
von radikalen Kräften bereitet Sorge
gerade an einem Datum wie heute dem
Jahrestag der Macht Ergreifung durch
Nationalsozialisten
dieser 30 Januar 33 hatte einen langen
langen Vorlauf von Zerstörung der
demokratischen Strukturen von Terror auf
den Straßen von Gewalt gegen
Andersdenkende und wir wissen wie es
geendet ist es sind tausende Leipziger
die heute auf die Straße gehen und die
auch dafür werben auch kontroverse
Meinungen in einer Demokratie
auszuhalten
wie Hitler vor 90 Jahren durch einen
demokratischen Prozess an die Macht kam
können Sie im Detail nachlesen bei ZDF
heute dort finden Sie auch die
dreiteilige ZDF-Dokumentation zum
Aufstieg eines unbekannten zum Diktator
Frauen in Deutschland verdienen immer
noch weniger als Männer durchschnittlich
18 Prozent das Statistische Bundesamt
erklärt das mit mehr Teilzeitarbeit und
geringerer Bezahlung in manchen
frauentypischen Berufen aber selbst bei
vergleichbarer Tätigkeit bekommen Frauen
immer noch 7% weniger während die
Gewerkschaften ein eklatantes
gerechtigkeitsproblem sehen sprechen
Wirtschaftsvertreter von nicht
vergleichbaren Erwerbsbiografie
Betriebe wurden geschont bei Kindern und
Schulen sei man sehr hart eingestiegen
mit dieser deutlichen Einsicht räumt
Karl Lauterbach Fehler in der
corona-politik ein er war damals noch
nicht Minister aber an wichtigen
Entscheidungen beteiligt die Schulen und
die Kitas so lange geschlossen zu halten
das war im Nachhinein ein Fehler auf der
anderen Seite ist es so damals wurde das
aber von den Wissenschaftlern die die
Bundesregierung beraten haben angeraten
Corona und lockdowns das hat auch die
Schwimmbäder schwer getroffen dann kam
im Herbst die nächste Prüfung wegen der
Energiekrise sollten Sie Ihr Wasser
runterkühlen viele Gäste begannen zu
frösteln und blieben Weg jetzt sind die
Sparauflagen gelockert und die ersten
Schwimmbäder versuchen mit ein paar Grad
mehr Kunden zurückzugewinnen Thomas
münden
es ist wieder wärmer im soll bei
Hallenbad in Rheinberg am Niederrhein
sogar zu warm
30,4 Grad im Nichtschwimmerbecken das
war jetzt lange anders seit Herbst war
das Wasser nur knapp 28 Grad warm gerade
für Kinder hatte das keinen
Wohlfühlfaktor weiß der verwaltungsschef
wir stellen insbesondere fest dass immer
mehr Krankmeldungen von Schülerinnen und
Schülern ein fliegen von Eltern die
irgendwie Sorge haben dass ihre Kinder
Erkältungskrankheiten davontragen
deshalb geht es jetzt wieder rauf mit
der Temperatur damit die Schwimmkurse
wieder voller werden heute morgen
schwimmt hier niemand aber auf der
Straße sind die Bürger trotzdem angetan
ist so ein bisschen steht bei mir so ein
bisschen für Wellness und da muss es
mollig warm sein es war okay zum
schwimmen aber wenn man so nur so dahin
schwimmen Becken hängen will da ist
schon ein bisschen kalt 12 Prozent mehr
Gas verbraucht das Bad jetzt wieder wenn
andere Bäder dem Rheinberger Beispiel
folgen steigt der Gasverbrauch in
Deutschland spürbar an aber das treibt
der Bundesnetzagentur keine
Schweißperlen auf die Stirn also die
Mengen über die wir hier reden an Gas
sind jetzt nicht die über das Wohl und
Wehe bei uns entscheiden wir kriegen ja
Gas Importe über die lng-terminals also
unser Nachbarländern aber wenn wir alle
zusammen sparen und sparsam und achtsam
sind dann hilft uns das in der
Vorbereitung auf den nächsten Winter in
Rheinberg hoffen sie jetzt wieder auf
mehr Schwimmer die sich bei 30 Grad
Wassertemperatur wohl fühlen
jetzt zum Fußball Fußball-Bundesliga
Bilanz des ersten
rückrundenspieltags Norbert um Bewegung
unten tut sich nichts Stuttgart Hertha
und S04 weiter am Tabellenende Schalke
gestern nur 0:0 gegen Köln der Reviere
war der Dortmund dagegen im zweiten
Sonntagsspiel erfolgreich in Leverkusen
ist jetzt Tabellen viertermin mit nur
noch drei Punkten Abstand auf die
führenden Bayern es läuft derzeit rund
beim BVB die Mannschaft einer Einheit
heiß auf den Ball früher attackierend
mit dem nötigen Esprit wie beim
Führungstreffer Allee überlässt es den
besser postierten adejemi den Angriff zu
vollenden sein erster Bundesliga Treffer
wir wollen den nächsten Schritt gehen
das heißt wir wollen in den Regionen wo
wir jetzt sind weiter bleiben und weiter
angreifen und dafür war es halt ein
guter Schritt ein bisschen Glück gegen
die zuletzt so starken Leverkusener
kommt hinzu die Schafe Hereingabe von
Wolf prallt vom Schienbein von tabsobar
ins Netz ein Eigentor macht den dritten
Sieg in Folge perfekt die Schwarz-Gelben
nur noch drei Punkte hinter
Spitzenreiter München aber das Wort
Bayern-Jäger geht ihnen noch nicht über
die Lippen
und alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des
Spieltags übrigens zu sehen bei heute.de
und in der heute App der neue
Weltmeister ist der alte Weltmeister im
Handball Dänemark gestern Abend der
hochverdiente Sieg gegen Frankreich ihr
das Tor von Matthias Gipfel zum 34 zu 29
entstand Dänemark ist das erste Team das
dreimal nacheinander den WM-Titel
gewonnen hat
[Applaus]
Matthias Kitzel wurde übrigens als
wertvollster Spieler ins Allstar-Team
des Turniers gewählt ebenso zwei
deutsche die Auszeichnung bester
Torhüter der WM erhielt Andreas Wolf ja
und der 22-Jährige Juri Knorr darf sich
bester Youngster dieser
Weltmeisterschaft nennen neben dem guten
fünften Platz für das Team 2 besondere
einzelauszeichen
und er muss sich noch auszeichnen als
neuer Trainer des deutschen Eishockey
Teams Harold Kreis bis Saisonende noch
Coach in Schwenningen erhält einen
3-Jahresvertrag der deutschkanadier wird
Nachfolger von Toni Söderholm Co-Trainer
wird der frühere NHL Verteidiger
Alexander
und dann wünschen wir den beiden doch
viel Glück ne unbedingt dankeschön das
Wetter bleibt windig und wechselhaft wo
genau es regnet schneit und stürmt
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja horneffer
Anne Gellinek freut sich auf Sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn hier
übernimmt morgen Jana pareikes machen
sie es gut einen schönen Abend noch und
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute gab es orkanartige
Sturmböen zum Beispiel auf Spiekeroog
und auch im Erzgebirge sie hängen
zusammen mit diesem Sturmtief das weiter
nach Osten gezogen ist und dieses Sturm
die fragt uns kräftige Regenschauer mit
das waren Schnee und Regenschauer sie
sehen den Schnee hier z.B im Erzgebirge
in weiß oder auch im Bayerischen Wald
und es waren auch Gewitter dabei jetzt
gibt's eine kurze Wetterberuhigung aber
wirklich nur kurz denn hier über Island
sehen Sie schon den eindrucksvollen
wolkenkringel des nächsten Sturmtiefs
heute Nacht fällt also Schneeregen hier
in Sachsen noch und auch in Bayern sonst
sind nur noch wenige Schauer unterwegs
es kann Platz sein auf den Straßen bei
Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus 4 und
-4 Grad und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 1 Grad in
Oberfranken und acht Grad im Nordwesten
und morgen kommt der nächste Regen und
auch wieder Schnee erstmal liegt die
Schneefallgrenze sogar 800 Meter kommt
im Laufe des Tages aber auf 400 m runter
und bis zum Abend erreichen die
schneeregenfälle dann auch den Spessart
Freund hier sieht es aus zwischen dem
Allgäu und dem Oberrhein und nachmittags
kommt die Sonne auch an der Nordseeküste
raus die nächsten Sturm gibt es dann am
Mittwoch und am Donnerstag reicht es am
Alpenrand vielleicht für 50 cm Neuschnee
guten Abend